>> WELCOME TO "CONNECT THE
WORLD."
I'M BECKY ANDERSON.
>>> THE BELGIANS AND NETHERLANDS
WERE HIT WITH EXTREME RAINFALL.
NOW NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES ARE
HELPING WITH WHAT ARE SEARCH AND
RESCUE OPERATIONS.
IN GERMANY AND CHRIS BURNS IS IN
NEIGHBORING BELGIUM.
SAM, LET'S START WITH YOU.
THESE FLOODS ARE THE LIKES OF
WHICH MOST PEOPLE WILL HAVE
NEVER SEEN.
WHAT IS GOING ON, ON THE GROUND?
>> Reporter: WELL, YOU SAID THE
LIKE OF WHICH PEOPLE HAVEN'T
EVER SEEN BEFORE.
DOWN IN THE NETHERLANDS, WHERE I
WAS A FEW DAYS AGO, THEY HAD THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF WATER AS A
RESULT OF THIS INUNDATION THAT
THEY'VE SEEN SINCE 1911.
SIMILAR STATISTICS APPLY RIGHT
ACROSS GERMANY.
LOOK AT THE DEVASTATION HERE
BEHIND ME, BECKY.
THIS HAS BEEN, IN A SENSE,
BECOME THE KIND OF SYMBOLIC TOWN
FOR THE WHOLE OF THE DEVASTATION
THAT HAS BEEN VISITED IN
GERMANY, THE COUNTRY WORST
AFFECTED WITH SOME 160 OR MORE
CASUALTIES, MANY HUNDREDS OF
OTHER PEOPLE UNACCOUNTED FOR,
NOT NECESSARILY MISSING.
FLASH FLOODS, NOT RIVERS, FLASH
FLOOD, GIGANTIC.
HIT ON ALMOST PERPENDICULAR
SLOPES, REALLY, REALLY
FRIGHTENING.
ON TOP OF THAT, THERE'S BEEN
FEARS THAT DAMS MIGHT BURST,
DOWN RIVER FROM WHERE I'M
STANDING NOW TODAY, THIS WAS THE
SCENE.
>> A BUSINESS RUINED, SLUNG AWAY
ALMOST AS QUICKLY AS IT WAS
WASHED AWAY.
FLASH FLOODING ENGULFED THIS
VIETNAMESE RESTAURANT.
HER FATHER FILMED THE RISING
WATERS, ONE OF THE MANY TOWNS
ENGULFED BY FLOODS THAT HAVE
KILLED AT LEAST 158 PEOPLE
ACROSS WESTERN GERMANY.
>> A LOT OF FRIENDS THEY HAVE
RESTAURANT, HOUSE, COMPLETELY
DESTROYED I HAVE A LOT OF
FRIENDS, THE HOUSE IS NOT
STANDING.
>> Reporter: THE RESTAURANT HAD
ONLY BEEN OPEN TWO WEEKS SINCE
THE MOST RECENT COVID
RESTRICTIONS HAD BEEN LIFTED.
NOW SHE'S RELIANT ON FRIENDS AND
FORMER DINERS TO HELP CLEAN UP.
>> THE DISASTER THAT ENGULFED
THIS TOWN WASN'T THE RESULT OF A
SWOLLEN RIVER BURSTING ITS BANKS
BUT THE RESULT OF FLASH
FLOODING, MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
RAINFALL COMING IN AN INCREDIBLY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
OFTEN THIS HIGH.
SWOLLEN RIVERS, THE FUTURE OF
THE DAM, PARTS OF IT COLLAPSED
AND SEVERAL RIVERS BELOW IT
EVACUATED.
ENGINEERS WERE RUSHED IN TO
BRING ITS LEVELS DOWN BEFORE IT
BURST.
SCENES LIKE THIS AND MUCH WORSE.
RAINFALL HAS HIT THE
NETHERLANDS, AUSTRIA AND CZECH
REPUBLIC.
WHILE MANY ARE GRIEVING THERE IS
AN ENERGETIC SENSE OF COMMUNITY
AS CLEANING UP STARTS.
>> I DON'T KNOW FROM WHO OR
WHERE THE GENERATORS COME FROM,
WHERE ALL THE PUMPS COME FROM.
I DON'T KNOW THE PEOPLE AROUND
HERE BUT EVERYBODY IS HELPING
EACH OTHER.
>> Reporter: THE COST OF THIS
DISASTER ARE ALMOST
INCALCULABLE.
CLIMATE CHANGE CRISIS, IT'S
LIKELY TO SAY THIS WAS A
WARNING.
NOW, BECKY, SINCE THAT PIECE,
WE'VE BEEN SPEAKING OR SEEN A
STATEMENT FROM HANNAH CLOAKS,
BRITISH ACADEMIC AT UNIVERSITY,
PART OF THE GROUP IN CHARGE OF
ISSUING WARNINGS AGAINST EXACTLY
THIS KIND OF DISASTER ACROSS
WESTERN EUROPE.
AND SHE HAS SAID THAT THE
FAILURE OF GOVERNMENTS TO
RESPOND TO THE WARNINGS THAT
THEY WERE GIVEN HAS BEEN
INEXCUSABLE, BECKY.
>> CERTAINLY ANGELA MERKEL
CALLING THESE SCENES SURREAL.
LET'S GET TO CHRIS IN BELGIUM.
600 PEOPLE THERE REMAIN
UNACCOUNTED FOR.
WHAT ARE AUTHORITIES DOING TO
NARROW THE SEARCH?
AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOW IN THE
THROES OF A MASSIVE CLEANUP,
WHAT IS GOING ON TO SUPPORT
THEM, CHRIS?
>> Reporter: BECKY, THE SEARCH
DOES GO ON.
IT'S COMPLICATED BY GAS LEAKS
WHICH WE WERE EVACUATED FROM IN
ONE SEARCH AND HERE WE ARE
LOOKING AT MASSIVE CLEANUP
EFFORTS THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
DOING, THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
DOING.
AND THEY'RE ALSO LIVING WITH
WHAT HAPPENED LAST THURSDAY
NIGHT.
IN FACT, LET ME BRING YOU OVER
HERE TO ONE OF THESE BUILDINGS
OVER HERE.
WE TALKED TO ONE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO EVACUATED AT THE LAST
MINUTE.
SHE SAW THE WATER, A NEIGHBOR
TAPPED ON HER WINDOW AND TOLD
HER THIS.
>> Translator: I WAS SLEEPING.
IT WAS MY NEIGHBOR WHO TAPPED ON
MY WINDOW TO WARN ME BECAUSE THE
WATER WAS UP TO MY WINDOW.
AFTER THAT, I TOOK THE
INITIATIVE.
I WARNED MY OTHER NEIGHBORS AND
TOOK REFUGE WITH MY NEIGHBOR ON
THE SECOND FLOOR THAT NIGHT.
>> Translator: HOW DID YOU FEEL?
IT MUST HAVE BEEN TERRIFIED,
LOOK OUT THE WINDOW AND THE
WATER RISING.
HOW DID YOU FEEL?
>> Translator: I WAS ALL
CONFUSED.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
MY PRIORITY WAS TO SAVE MY
NEIGHBOR.
LIKE MY NEIGHBOR SAVED ME I HAD
TO SAVE MY NEIGHBOR ON THE FLOOR
ABOVE, TOO.
>> Reporter: SO AURIELLE AND
OTHERS HERE, ONLY 40% HAVE
ELECTRICITY.
THEY CAN'T DRINK THE WATER AND
THERE'S GROWING ANGER ABOUT THE
FACT THAT PERHAPS OFFICIALS
COULD HAVE WARNED A BIT EARLIER
AND EVEN THE MAYOR TOLD US IN AN
INTERVIEW, WE HOPE TO PLAY YOU
THAT THE NEXT HOUR, THAT THEY
COULD HAVE BEEN EVACUATED AND
AVOIDED A LOT OF DEATHS.
BECKY?
>> IS ENOUGH BEING DONE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN GET
INSURANCE CLAIMS EXECUTED?
WHAT'S THE STORY ON THE GROUND?
>> Reporter: THAT'S A HUGE
QUESTION.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS SET ASIDE A
FEW MILLION FOR THE CLEANUP, HAS
SET ASIDE MILLIONS FOR SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS, FOR PEOPLE TO --
IT'S NOT NEARLY GOING TO BE
ENOUGH.
IT WILL BE A MUCH BIGGER BUDGET
ON THAT AND ABOUT THE BLAME
GAME.
THERE ARE CALLS BY THE MAYOR AND
OTHERS THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
NATIONAL INQUIRY AS TO WHY THERE
WAS A COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWN ON
WARNING PEOPLE TO GET AWAY FROM
THIS TSUNAMI THAT CRASHED
THROUGH HERE THURSDAY NIGHT,
THURSDAY MORNING.
>> SAM, YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THERE HAS BEEN MUCH
CRITICISM THAT THESE GOVERNMENTS
SHOULD HAVE -- THERE WAS ENOUGH
WARNING FROM FORECASTERS, THESE
GOVERNMENTS SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
AND MORE MIGHT HAVE BEEN DONE TO
WARN PEOPLE.
THERE IS, OF COURSE, A GREAT
CONNECTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE AT
THIS POINT.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ON THE
GROUND?
>> Reporter: I HAVEN'T SPOKEN TO
ANYONE WHO SAY VICTIM OF THIS
THAT DON'T BELIEVE IT'S A
CONSEQUENCE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THEY DON'T LIVE IN THE BUBBLE.
THEY LIVE ON THE GROUND.
I SPOKE TO NICHOLAS PETERS
MOMENTS AGO WHO SAID HE HAS BEEN
CLEANING UP HIS PARENTS'
DEVASTATED HOUSE.
HE SAID WHEN YOU SEE 50-DEGREE
TEMPERATURES IN CANADA MIDSUMMER
DON'T BE SURPRISED IF WE SEE
THESE EVENTS HAPPENING AM
EUROPE.
BY THE WAY, THERE HAVE BEEN MASS
FLOODING EVENTS IN CENTRAL
WESTERN EUROPE AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM FREQUENTLY THE LAST 10
TO 15 YEARS.
AND AGAIN, PROFESSOR AT
UNIVERSITY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
STUDYING THIS STUFF HAS DRAWN AN
ABSOLUTE RED LINE BETWEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE AND WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE WIDER CLIMATE CHANGE
DEBATE.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE IS
INTERESTED IN DEBATING WHETHER
THIS WAS A RESULT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IT WOULD BE CONSIDERED FOOLI